this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
good evening breaking news off the top
here at five as exclusive intense new
video shows officers responding to a
deadly chase on i-15 thanks for joining
us i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis that incident claiming the life
of nhp trooper micah may orco mana has a
closer look at the new footage
[Music]
this new video really gives us an idea
of how intense the situation was that
day on the i-15 nhp trooper micah may
was trying to deploy stop sticks to stop
a carjacking suspect when that suspect
hit him we're about to show the moments
right after officers were able to stop
the suspect and we want to warn you this
video may be difficult to watch for some
viewers
you can hear the shock in the officer's
voices learning trooper may went through
the windshield of the car those gunshots
you heard were officers opening fire on
the suspect who died at the scene it's
believed he was reaching for trooper
may's weapon trooper may did not survive
we've seen an outpouring of support from
the community for trooper may and his
family following this tragic incident if
you'd like to see the full nearly 30
minute video from metro police head to
our website 8newsnow.com
orca mana 8 news now